20-17 hasn't been Hollywood's best year
at the box office
the rise of high quality entertainment
options outside of theaters combined
with sequel fatigue and rising prices
have helped contribute to a series of
domestic flops leaving the film industry
struggling to cope with increasingly
disappointing returns on their would-be
blockbusters these hugely expensive
high-profile releases have one thing in
common they all failed to deliver at the
box office
transformers the last night the
Transformers franchise has been a cash
cow for Paramount for years but the
long-running series tumbled with the
last night the movie which brought sir
Anthony Hopkins into the fold alongside
Mark Wahlberg to expose the secret
history of the Transformers was made on
a 217 million dollar budget but only
grows slightly over 130 million dollars
at the domestic box office there are a
few things that can be blamed for the
last night's disappointing domestic
performance including a slow summer
box-office that was unkind to several
sequels and long-running franchises the
film was also trashed by critics and
faced tough competition from guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 and Wonder Woman
both of which had better reviews while
the last night failed to deliver in the
States it still did well overseas
pulling in nearly six hundred million
dollars this is still well below the
worldwide performances for previous
Transformers installments Dark of the
Moon and age of extinction but paramount
has shown no signs of slowing down with
the franchise the next release and a tea
set spin-off focusing on the popular
bumblebee character is due out in
December of 2018 malaria and the city of
a thousand planets Luke based on loud
sci-fi fans with The Fifth Element in
Lucy but he wasn't able to do it again
with valerian and the city of a thousand
planets the movie starred Cara
Delevingne
and Dane DeHaan as to intergalactic
agents on a quest to save the universe
and was a massive flop at the box office
pulling in just under 40 million dollars
in the US on a nearly 180 million dollar
budget
valerian had a few things standing in
its way for one it's young stars while
both up and comers weren't very well
known
nor was the comic on which it's based
reviews were also just average which
wasn't enough to push through the movies
confusing advertising valerian also
faced tough competition opening the same
weekend as Christopher Nolan's Dunkirk
and just shortly after spider-man
homecoming and more for the Planet of
the Apes King Arthur legend of the sore
Guy Ritchie tried to launch a franchise
with King Arthur legend of the sewer a
175 million dollar epic that starred
Charlie Hunnam as the title character
however the film suffered a massively
disappointing box office run bringing in
just 39 million dollars domestic to kick
off a stagnant summer King Arthur was
plagued by bad omens from the start the
movie came out after many many years of
attempts to make another film about the
character following 2004's king Arthur
you've got some heat on the author your
name keeps coming up reports say
Ritchie's script was a messy mashup that
combined elements of all the failed
projects that came before on top of that
the movie saw its release date delayed
multiple times which is rarely a good
sign King Arthur also suffered some
pretty dismal reviews amassing a 29
percent on Rotten Tomatoes while the
international box office did provide
some relief the movie is estimated to be
a 150 million dollar loss for Warner
Brothers you'll give me a date the great
wall with Matt Damon in the lead and a
bunch of weird monsters on the attack it
seemed reasonable to expect that the
great wall would be a hit however a
whitewashing controversy and bad reviews
pre-staged it's miserable box office run
which brought in just 45 million dollars
domestic against a 150 million dollar
budget plus marketing the great wall was
set to pull together the power of
Chinese and American audiences to
deliver what should have been a massive
blockbuster but approved the domestic
dud perhaps in part due to the
controversy surrounding Damon's white
Savior narrative the movie also received
the ire of critics hitting just 35
percent on Rotten Tomatoes the movie is
said to have lost more than 75 million
dollars a monumental loss for the
investors The Mummy universals plans to
launch a monster movie universe hit an
early snag
when they're rebooted the mummy made
just 80 million dollars domestic on a
one hundred and twenty five million
dollar budget the mummy started to
unravel early on when it faced dismal
reviews from critics
and a slow summer box office that was
unfriendly towards reboots also didn't
help many people thought the mummy was
also bogged down by its efforts to try
to launch a cinematic universe right
away
unlike the Marvel Cinematic Universe it
immediately went gung-ho towards setting
up something bigger an effort that took
precedence over simply making a good
film and we're all gonna come up with a
new plan while the international box
office was enough to keep Universal from
scuttling their dark universe altogether
there are definitely many lessons to be
unwrapped from The Mummy monster trucks
paramount new monster trucks
the CGI heavy blockbuster about a
monster who well lives in a truck would
be a flop long before the movie hit
theaters in January
Viacom paramount parent company already
wrote off 115 million dollars for the
expected bad performance of the still
unreleased film when it finally arrived
in theaters it realized the studio's
worst fears grossing just thirty three
point three million dollars domestic
against a one hundred and twenty five
million dollar budget kids will love
this movie because explosions monsters
really fast trucks except they didn't at
first the studio had high hopes for
monster trucks which they thought could
launch a Transformers type franchise
however the film was pushed back
multiple times and it eventually came
out to the derision of critics and was a
monster disappointment Blade Runner 2049
sure Blade Runner 2049 received
rapturous reviews thanks to its stunning
visuals and ability to both update and
honor the original film's classic story
however its vocal fans were not able to
help the movie make a big splash at the
box office with the film opening to less
than 32 million dollars at the domestic
box office against a 150 million dollar
budget one of the biggest issues was the
film's extremely long runtime coming in
at a whopping 163 minutes which may have
dissuaded casual moviegoers and limited
the number of showings a theater could
hold in a day the film also relied on
fans in the original film to turnout and
while many of them did Blade Runner
wasn't exactly a box-office success
during its first run either in the end
the biggest thing standing in Blade
Runner 2049 sway was itself the film was
a stunning visual feast and making
something that beautiful clearly wasn't
going to come cheap Gio stormed the
expensive disaster flick Gio Storm faced
a chilly reception during its opening
weekend and it wasn't because of
malfunctioning weather machines the
movie starring Gerard Butler as a
scientist tasked with saving the planet
after the satellites keeping the
dangerous effects of climate change at
bay malfunction cost upwards of 120
million dollars to make but brought in
just thirteen point three million
dollars in its opening weekend
suggesting an expensive failure for the
studio inside it's worse than we thought
Gio Storm was a troubled production from
the start its release date was pushed
back multiple times as the studio
brought on mega producer Jerry
Bruckheimer to oversee costly reshoots
to fix a reportedly unwatchable first
cut its fate was sealed when it earned
the ire of critics who gave it an
unlucky 13 percent on Rotten Tomatoes on
top of all of that the movie hit
theaters in an awful time premiering
just a few short weeks
after a trio of hurricanes devastated
large parts of the United States and the
Caribbean talk about a disaster movie
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]